بعد غياب دام 36 عاما حقق المنتخب
الارجنتيني حلم الملايين ورفع عقائده
الاسطوري ليونيل ميسي الكاس الاغلى في
سماء ستاد لوسيل في العاصمه القطريه
الدوحه فرحه عامه ترجمه عملا جاوبا من
كتيبه ليونال سكالوني بدات بخساره امام
المنتخب السعودي وانتهت بتتويج مستحقه على
حساب المنتخب الفرنسي في نهائي تاريخي
الانجاز والحلوم الاكبر كما وصفه قائد
المنتخب الارجنتين ليونيل ميسي انه تحقق
وتتابعت عاقبه الانتصار الحلم ردود
الافعال من رياضيين واساطير سابقين
وسياسيين ايضا الاسطوره البرازيلي بيليه
الفائز بكاس العالم ثلاث مرات كتب قائله
اليوم تواصل كره القدم
سردا قصتها كما هو الحال دائما بطريقه
اسره فاز ميسي بكاس العالم للمره الاولى
كما تستحق مسيرته
يا لها من هديه مشاهده هذا المشهد لمستقبل
رياضه تهانينا للارجنتين بالتاكيد دييغو
مارادونا يبتسم الان
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
قائد منتخب ليونيل ميسي اللاعب الافضل في
كاس العالم فيفا قطر 2022 كان هو الحال
خلال السنوات الماضيه حديث المونديال
والصحافه حول العالم هل سيعتزل هل سيكون
المونديال الاخير في مسيره اللاعب
الاسطوره استشف العالم من حديثي ليه وانا
مونديال قطر سيكون الاخير في مسيرته
العبقريه وفقا تصريحاته السابقه لكن
القائد الاسطوري وفي غمره الفرحه العارمه
بتتويجه بكاس العالم امس
نيته استكمال المسيره مع منتخب بلاده
قائلا انه يود اللعب للمنتخب للمنتخب وهو
بطل العالم بالتاكيد سير غابه كل ارجنتيني
باستمرار القائد ميسي في صفوف المنتخب
وكذلك يرغب محب الرجل حول العالم لكن في
المذيعه المقبل 2026 سيكون عمر ليو 38
عاما ولا يستطيع احد سوى ميسي نفسه ان
يحدد متى يوقف قطاره مع المنتخب واللاعب
الدو لكن فعلها لوكا مودريتش وكريستيانو
رونالدو اللذين لعب المونديال بعمر 38
عاما و 39 عاما على التوالي فهل ينوي ماس
فعلها
[موسيقى]